Hey going on.
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I am just checking in on you.
My voice is still fucked up.
I got two more records people episode nine and number 10,
we're just broke.
Number 10,
we're almost done,
which means all freckles is going to do be doing a bunch of spots around loss of
Congolese getting ready for my European tour.
Tor,
Tor.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Which starts off in Dublin,
Ireland,
Dublin,
Ireland and a,
you know what's funny is I tried to uh,
on,
on July 31st it starts off and I tried to get a,
you know,
get a direct flight to the Emerald Aisle and the uh,
at this point because waited so long to get the fucking tickets,
um,
you know,
which is a whole other story in itself,
you know what I mean?
Cause I'm going to take a vacation with my wife afterwards and she was trying to
figure out where the fuck we were going to go.
And I was like,
lady,
Yep.
You better fucking figure out a place soon cause this is going to cost me a
fortune there.
Um,
so,
uh,
it turns out the out of lax,
the only two airlines,
it was air Lingus and um,
uh,
what the fuck is it?
Oh Jesus,
I already forgot the name of the,
what the hell is an Ethiopian airlines
figured that one out.
I don't want to fly Ethiopian Airlines unless I'm going to like,
you know,
Ethiopia,
Aer Lingus,
the Irish one.
You know,
is that weird?
Like if I'm going to go to the Middle East,
I want to fly,
uh,
that whatever United Arab Emirates.
I don't,
it's just weird superstition that I have like the people at Ethiopian Airlines
don't care because they're flying to Ireland.
Does that make any sense?
It doesn't,
that's just how scary flying us.
Like if I'm going to Poland,
I want a couple of Polish guy flying it despite all the jokes about them.
Hey,
how many Polish guys is it take to fly a plane?
A fucking,
hopefully two of them,
you know,
that studied
all this shit they needed to know.
So aer Lingus was more expensive,
and I said,
well fuck it.
I'm going to take the,
I don't even know if that's the Irish one for some reason.
I think that's the one with the four leaf clover.
Oh,
is it?
They've got a Leprechaun on the fucking tail fin.
Let me look this up.
Aer Lingus Lattie every Irish guy's giving me shit about my bad accident.
Like I give a fuck.
All right.
Aer Lingus images.
Yeah,
there it is.
Oh,
it's a three leaf clover.
I've put another fucking leaf on there yet.
Cuts.
Make me feel a little better.
Oh,
Jesus.
Is that the best plane they got?
Oh boy.
That looks like just some shit from the early seventies.
All right,
let's look at Ethiopia.
Where Ethiopian Airlines,
there's no food on this plane.
Sorry.
Ethiopian Airlines.
Let's see what we got here.
What do we got here?
Okay.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
Both of these planes still look these,
neither one of these,
uh,
very,
look at the stewardesses.
They look pretty fucked.
They didn't have any stewards for the Irish ones.
They probably all hammered.
Could I have any more stereotypes in this?
MMM.
All right.
They both have professional whose kid?
No,
you don't what it is once you travel outside of your own country.
You know what I mean?
I fly American Airlines,
I fly United,
I fly shit that I've heard of.
I've always done that.
Except early on in my career when I used to fly like fucking,
what the fuck was that one?
It was air something or other.
I felt fluid.
Ata.
I mean,
you flew on that fucking airlines.
They,
it was like,
like the cabin to the stuffed of cockpit was open.
They were up there playing like connect four and shit.
It was,
it was really bad.
I have to,
I'll tell you it was bad,
you know?
Um,
no,
it was,
it was just like,
it was still weird to sing.
You'd been in an in an airport and just feeling like you were in America and
then you'd get on a ta and you will literally felt like you were leaving a war
torn country.
Like you just look around like,
what a fuck all these extras come from.
Am I am I gonna my in some fucking a George Clooney movie that's some important
George,
one of those selling arms for some shit,
you know,
a very important story that needed to be tell w told we are filmmakers and this
is what we do.
You know George,
they said this script was floating around Hollywood for a while.
Well you know,
I'm good.
Look at it and I said I'm going to do it.
So it got made.
Um Oh,
I got a call out fucking Michael Rappaport.
Okay,
okay.
And you know you would think that I'm going to call him out for the fact that
his resting face,
you never heard of resting bitch face.
You don't want his face looks like it looks like you remember that face Danny
Ainge would make after he got called for a foul.
That's what his resting face looks like.
All right.
Now I love this man except what he talks sports.
I've never seen somebody hate on Boston sports the way he does.
Right?
So he wrote some more bullshit about Boston sports.
So I call him up breaking his balls going through,
you know,
what you wrote is in true laughing.
We have a great fucking time.
He goes on the Internet like some real housewife whore who were right and you
know what he said?
He said,
wow,
bill Burgess called me up like,
uh,
threatening big Blahblahblah and all this fucking a,
he's a,
he's tweeting like some Instagram whore that's just trying to get fucking
followers.
I don't understand Michael.
Somebody send you into this clip right now.
I even told them how fucking bitchy he was being above Boston sports.
My Q,
I guess he was freaking out that uh,
that the Celtics might get Kevin Durant,
which um,
you know,
who's getting it with the whole free agency game.
This is how it works as a fan,
everybody doesn't like it unless the free agent comes to their team.
That's basically it.
But at the end of the day,
even when they do come to the a team in the back of your head,
you know,
it's bullshit,
right?
I mean,
what happened?
Yo,
you're,
you're getting fucked over by your team.
You want to go make some more money,
fine.
But I'm talking to when you were an elite fucking player and you go to pile on
another fucking team.
And I'm talking as a Celtics fan when we did that.
And what was it?
Oh wait.
Okay.
The only thing that made a decent was that the Lakers had a bunch of free
agents.
So we met in the finals and it was sort of,
it was like the 80s in that those two teams were in the finals back to back
years.
But I mean it was,
it was bullshit.
Like I don't look at the Oh eight Celtics,
like it was a blur.
We went from last place to first place,
we won the fucking thing and then we played them again next year in the finals
and the referee is called 9,000 files on us and like 15 on the fucking Lakers.
And for some reason that was considered a good game.
Seven,
I don't know.
Uh,
but that's the NBA,
you know,
every once in a while they have a mobbed up ref,
Patrick Ewing goes to the Knicks.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a business.
Um,
but I think,
cause I,
when I look at the NFL where they got the parody there and uh,
all of a sudden,
you know,
the Seahawks out of fucking nowhere can win one,
fucking Patriot stunk for fucking ever.
All of a sudden we got good,
you go up,
you go down these guys when those guys,
you know,
it's nice and fucking everybody kind of has a chance now and that's been great.
Their ratings are better than ever as far as I know.
And I think the,
the route that the NBA is going is they create these super teams and people hate
them so much that they watch rooting for them to loose.
And um,
I dunno,
I liked it better.
I mean back in the day,
like I said,
there was free agency in that type of shit,
but it wasn't just the way it is now.
The amount of times where people pull the old Johnny Damon where you've,
well I guess Damon one with the red sox and then like the next year or whatever,
he goes to the fucking Yankees.
It's just like what Jesus Christ.
Can you,
can you ease your way around the fact that it's just a business and it's all
about money,
you know?
Um,
I dunno,
I actually don't know how Kevin Durant really helps the warriors in a way.
You know,
they had their two guys that were the guys and then he's coming in and in a lot
of ways he's at least number two,
depending on what you think about the fucking,
the fucking honor roll student there.
Um,
I dunno,
I know people say they just want to win,
but I think egos get hurt when you know,
you,
you used to get 25 points a game and now you're down to like 21 or 19.
I Dunno,
we'll see what the fuck happens.
But,
uh,
sucked.
I was really hoping he was going to stay in Oklahoma.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I was hoping that,
uh,
you know,
after last year where they were up three games to one,
that they were going in the off season and be like,
you know what the fuck happened?
We don't know how.
We don't know how to win.
We don't know how to close somebody out.
And what I loved about watching the warriors come back against Oklahoma as much
as I was Rooney for Oklahoma,
and she got to watch a championship team
like w w what the warriors did,
being down three games to one coming back in that series was,
it was fucking hilarious to me.
Like watching them,
it was like,
you remember the horror movie?
Like they never changed their pace when they went down,
they didn't panic.
They just kept coming.
You know,
it was like those old school monster movies from the 80s where the fucking Jason
Guy,
right is just walking and the victim is running away.
He's the victim's running,
the monsters walking,
but the person running keeps looking over their shoulder.
So they keep tripping over logs and shit.
Right?
So eventually the fucking dude with the hatchet walks him down and puts him out
of their misery.
That's what,
that's what fucking the warriors did to Oklahoma.
Oh Geez.
I'm searching it.
Was that too sophisticated for you?
You know,
I got to tell you,
watching the warriors coming back against Oklahoma was like watching Friday the
13th part three,
the Oh Geez.
Um,
so I've seen a bunch of teams do that be better than the other team.
They just didn't know how to fucking win.
And then what happens is,
as a sports fan,
you get to watch them learn how to win.
You get to watch him.
Sure as hell.
Fuck a tape.
That's what you get to watch.
Unless the best guy goes,
you know what?
I don't feel like learning that's going to go join the team that came back and
kicked our ass.
I mean,
can you imagine if movies were like that?
Okay.
All right.
This is like the nerd getting beat up by the bully.
You know,
there's like five nerds getting beat up by these five bullies,
right?
It's five on five.
Right.
And then the third act is not the fucking nerds figure out how to beat down the
bullies.
One of the nerds joins the other bullies and then helps them go back and beat up
all his friends.
Okay.
I mean,
granted,
I guess I'd kind of be funny if you're a sick fuck like me,
but at the end of the day that that kind of movie is that,
well,
maybe act two was that he goes to fucking golden state and then act three is he
comes back and he has one of those Lebron James type movies.
I don't fucking know.
All I know is that a,
you know,
I kind of got back into the NBA this year.
I started watching the Celtics and that type of shit and that was a great
rivalry out west and now it's no more.
Okay.
Did you hear what she barked back?
Oh,
it's a great Boston named dude.
Fucking Chow's Buckley said fucking Kevin Durant's it cheetah
not shaking like Tom Brady.
That was bullshit.
Cheek like Kevin Durant.
He's not on our team,
so I'll hold them to the fizz feet to the fire.
Um,
uh,
not cheating like Jim or say
he said that.
Yeah,
he's trying to cheat his way to a championship.
He used the wrong word,
but I understand what he's saying.
He's just,
he's just a fucking,
yeah,
he just,
he left the nerd table.
He CA's go on to the bully table and then he's gonna come back and beat up the
nurse.
It'd be like,
well,
look and make,
I'm a tough guy over here.
Um,
isn't it amazing how much taller Kevin Durant's than me and I'm still giving him
shit.
That's the wonderful thing about podcasting is you can fucking talk shit within
the safety of your own living room.
All right,
whatever.
I'm going to get off this fucking topic,
but,
uh,
I did in fact to confirm Michael Rappaport real housewife tweet,
by the way,
is there anyone,
can somebody please Photoshop him into one of those real housewife fucking
thinks.
We had a great conversation laughing our balls off when we came to an agreement
in the end of it and that Danny Ainge looking,
motherfucker goes on the Internet and he tweets 180 letters or less about me.
By the way,
I have to apologize for,
I love Michael Rep before I,
you know,
okay.
Every time I see him,
I always feel like this is the last time I'm ever going to see him.
You know?
There's just something about him.
Even though he's younger than me,
he just moves around like he's in his eighties I think he has that disease.
You know that disease Brad Pitt had in that movie where he was like a fucking
old baby.
Whenever the fuck happened.
I don't know if that's what he wrote.
He reminded no,
I was just a fable.
Right.
What was it called?
A fairy tale.
Whatever.
He fucking,
he's like that,
you know?
You know like when a fucking eight year old looks like this 70 whatever that
disease is called.
[inaudible]
MMM.
I was going to see George Michael.
That's not,
that wasn't the guy who was the guy who played on Ohio state going to Portland.
That port pastored the micro fractures in his feet like he's playing in China
now.
I can't remember.
All I'm thinking is haven Moses and I know he played for the Broncos in the 70s
I want to say his name was George wasn't there.
Okay.
We got to look this up now.
How State Ohio,
how state,
uh,
Portland
micro fracture.
Mike not microbrewery.
Get the fuck audio microphones.
Microbreweries are the worst sort of thing.
All right.
What's his name?
Greg [inaudible].
Michael Rappaport has Greg Oden Disease
Eight.
Does it like Greg Oden?
He got paid a ton of fucking money and he didn't follow through if we get paid
the,
uh,
national,
podcasting association drafted him,
number one to come on to end the podcasting world to talk about sports,
thinking that he was going to be unfair now thinking that he was going to be
biased and fair.
I can't even fucking talk this morning.
Oh my God,
I can't wait to do his podcast again.
You know?
Who's kidding?
Who were both a couple of real housewives?
You know what I mean?
I think I'm slightly better looking than him though.
Slightly,
you know,
and a little more mobile,
I think I bring a lot more to a team.
I'm like spike hour,
right?
Utility player him.
I don't know what he is.
He's like a fucking Rappaport's,
like a fucking,
you know,
he's like dead d h You know,
his career's over,
you know,
he can't touch his toes,
so they can't have him play first base.
He just sits on the bench seat and sunflower seeds gets up three,
four times a game.
Squinting into the fucking Sun.
He just sneaks through the fences,
grounds out and do a double play.
Kills the rally,
you know.
But he's got such a big contract,
they can't get rid of him.
Okay.
He's like Greg Luzinski if you went on a diet,
although,
no,
no disrespect to Greg Lissitzky.
All right.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about here.
Oh,
Formula One.
Right.
I needed to apologize.
Um,
because when I was say,
when I watched the Austrian Grand Prix that it was like fucking days a thought,
and I said,
Lewis Hamilton was like the Tom Cruise,
the upstart.
I add a completely wrong,
and I want to thank everybody on Twitter that set me straight so eloquently.
Hey,
fuck stick.
Um,
I guess Lewis Hamilton,
he's been,
he's,
he's won it three times.
He's a 31 fucking years old and he's already won the a for me one championship
three times.
He won it in 2008,
2014 and 2015 Nico Rosberg has never won.
So the reality is is that Nico was the Tom Cruise,
right?
And Lewis Hamilton is the val Kilmer.
He's the ice man.
That's right.
Ice Man.
I am dangerous.
And then Lewis Hamilton clicks his teeth together for no fucking reason,
right?
They're all sweaty and shit.
I Dunno.
All I know is the British Grand Prix is a,
is this fucking,
uh,
is this Sunday and that dude toto,
I swear to God,
that's his fucking nickname.
All I want to do when I wake up in the morning is not see the team crash.
Um,
sat down with them.
It was just like,
listen,
all right,
right stuff.
Fucking drive in and do each other,
mate.
Whatever the fuck he said.
I don't know where he's from.
I think he's just,
I think he is from Austria.
Who knows,
I'm new to this sport and I just like throwing up shit as fact.
You know what I mean?
And why would I,
why would I actually waste the time to read up on this sport when I can just
make big fucking statements and people on Twitter will correct me anyways,
you know,
then I don't have to look it up.
All I gotta do is just scroll,
you know,
so why these kids are so fucking dumb today.
You know,
they don't read books the way I used to,
you know,
three hours in,
I'm 17 pages in my fucking a DDS off the fucking charts,
right?
Sitting there reading about Tom Sawyer.
You don't think about,
I don't know what,
you know the Queen Mary God knows whatever was said in that fucking book that
made me think of something else.
Apples.
How's this some sort of arsenic in there?
And how many apples would you have to do eat to actually poison yourself?
You know,
eat so many fucking apples.
What do you think?
There's arsenic assumption of,
you know,
the apple,
some sort of poison,
I can't remember what.
But if you eat enough of them right,
you'd actually die.
And that somebody would actually get to say eulogy.
You know,
an apple a day
does in fact keep the doctor away.
But uh,
you know,
eat 42 of them,
you're gonna fucking die.
But you know what?
He died the fruit.
Um,
anyways,
let's,
let's read some of the fucking horse shit here for this week.
Let's read some of the advertising.
Shall We?
Is this,
it is just a simple safe.
What does that sound like?
Bad food.
All right.
No,
it isn't simple.
Safe.
All right.
Helux he licks your unique.
You don't waste.
You don't walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else.
Talk.
Walk,
shoot,
shed.
That sounded like the one that Marine Corps.
I'm going to teach you how to walk.
Talk.
[inaudible] cool.
All right.
You're,
you're unique.
Everybody.
You don't walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else or sweet like everyone else.
So why is your mattress you're so,
why is your mattresses so why is your mattress
Jedi?
You spell mattress.
Well how do you spell mistress?
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Gee,
I don't know.
I don't know cause you fucking cause it fits because it truly customized
mattress will cost you a five or 10,000 bucks.
Ah,
that's the reason.
Who the fuck has the money to do that?
They should get audited immediately.
Do you know I was watching one of those beret Jackson's one time and they had
one of those doughs GM that Pereda prod progress.
Fucking elephant van there.
Somebody spent four point $1 million on that fucking thing.
I was excited.
They got a good deal.
You know what I mean?
That guy either needs to get audited or he has his wife bound and gagged and a
fucking closet.
How you pull the,
hey,
hey honey,
look what I spent $4 million on a giant fucking toaster that you can drive.
What do you mean?
Why did I do that?
Rp Koa I liked.
I thought it was a good tee off.
Fuck you lady.
Right?
What are these things called?
Gm Parade.
This is still the advertiser Pereda progress.
I used to know what these things were called Pereda progress image,
the GM future line of look,
that fucking thing up.
I mean,
granted,
it's kind of cool,
but it is.
It's like an easy bake oven that you can drive and somebody paid four point $1
million for that fucking thing,
you know?
And all I said,
all I could think was what was he doing in 2008 when they fucking economy
crashed other than doing fucking cartwheels out the back door of whatever
fucking bank he worked at.
Oh bill is that social commentary?
You freckled can't just shut up and read the advertising.
All right,
here we go.
Hell looks everybody.
Helix.
I'm going to read this like a fucking yoga instructor here.
Unique.
You don't work like anyone else talk like anyone else.
They're sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because they truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks.
And how many starving children could that feed?
40 50 million for only half a cent today.
Somehow you can give somebody three square meals.
Oh an Ethiopian Airlines.
All right,
for cus your five to 10,000 bucks until now.
So go to x stuck sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions,
and they'll run a three d biomechanical model of your body through the
proprietary algorithms they've developed it.
Doesn't that sound like a bunch of bullshit?
Jmu Wham,
proprietary analytic algorithms?
I can't say it,
so it must be good.
Uh,
they developed with the help of the world's leading Aragon nomics and
biomechanics experts.
The results,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helix customers,
how IX report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality.
And for couples,
they customize each each side of the mattress.
Oh,
that's great.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from Gq magazine to Forbes aren't those the same people.
You get to the top of your bank and then all of a sudden you're like,
I'm going to have a yacht and fucking wavy brown hair with a fucking Rolex are
all talking about helic sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free.
Give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Go to hell.
You know what?
A lot of homeless people are gonna be getting a good night's then cause there's
no fucking way you can resell that.
Kenya or Kenya.
I don't fucking know.
All right.
Um,
just dump it on a sidewalk.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/burn and get $50 off your order.
That's helic sleep.com/burr hey,
he likes sleep.com/ [inaudible] all right,
and lastly,
but certainly not leastly.
Ah,
what's that rolled friend?
Zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
Come on,
wake up.
Do you want to find the perfect hire?
You need to post your job to all the top job sites and you can do it now.
All right,
with zip.
Okay.
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified candidates roll into zip.
Crudites easy to use interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates,
rate them,
look at the tits on her and hire the right person fast.
Find out why zip.
Okay.
Recruiter has been used by 800,000 businesses and right now listeners can try
zip recruiter for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/birth that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Go to zip
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible] all right,
there we go.
There we go.
To the perfect place,
the perfect play heights.
Um,
all right,
so once again,
my uh,
my European tour,
boop,
my euro peon motherfucking fucking tour.
Uh,
I am the,
I am going to fucking,
I am so excited about this tour.
All right,
I'm so excited.
I love going to Europe.
I love being everything that they want me to be.
Okay.
I'm sorry,
I'm not going to be fat on this one cause I been hitting the elliptical there,
but I am going to be,
I'm going to go over there,
right?
And I'm going to talk to them about the finer points of Donald Trump.
That's what I want to do,
especially in Scotland,
where they had the nerve to call our fucking orange headed.
Can't have fucking orange headed country.
You got a lot of fucking nerve Scotland calling an orange headed content orange
handed.
Countway me.
Why don't you look around your country.
There's plenty of orange headed conch there.
All right.
Okay.
We are,
we have very few here.
Every once a while they run for president when they're in between seasons of
their reality show.
Okay.
And what's great about our country's,
everybody truly does get a chance.
I'm like your countries.
I have no fucking idea what's going on over there.
Evidently England,
uh,
decided to not be part of the European Union.
Is that what happened?
I love how like as an American,
I'm supposed to know this shit,
a union that I'm not into.
I understand what's going on over there.
The banks are sewing up all your fucking countries.
It's like when you fucking buy a a,
a Co op,
you know,
versus the condo.
You buy a condo.
The person next to you.
It can be a fucking junkie who gives a shit.
You still got your condo.
But if you're in a co op playoffs,
if you're in a Co op,
this is the deal.
What you're,
you're not buying an apartment.
What you're doing is you're buying shares in the building,
but now you're tied in with the whole building.
So basically if your neighbor's enough of your neighbors go bankrupt and the
whole,
the whole building goes under,
you lose your shares and you either have to move out of your apartment or you go
back to renting it and you're like,
wait a minute,
I thought I bought it.
No,
no,
no sir.
You bought shares in the building.
You paid your way.
But these other cons didn't.
And because they didn't,
you go down to the bottom of the lagoon with them.
That to me is what the European Union is,
right?
And that's what banks want.
Right?
And they just fucking bankrupt him.
And,
uh,
I dunno what the fuck they do.
They play that little fucking game.
They buy low and then they fucking go high and I'll fuck,
could they pull the money out and everybody falls in their fucking ass and then
they got another castle.
You know?
I think that that's how the economy works,
right?
And it's all run by shape shifters.
Okay.
Just shit like that.
You know what I mean?
Especially when I'm in London and those stupid fucking critics show up
it fucking guys,
critics of the fucking worse.
There's nothing you can do.
There's no show that you can have that they're not going to rip the shit out of
it.
And it just fucking hilarious to me.
It's like I don't need critics.
All right.
If I wanted to feel bad about having a good show,
I just call my mom.
Oh,
fucking need you to be doing her job.
All right.
Whatever.
July 31st everybody.
Dublin,
Ireland.
All right.
Then August 1st I'm in Belfast.
I've never been there.
Belfast,
Ireland.
The fuck is his Belfast UK.
All right.
It's Ireland.
I think it's about time England got the fuck out of there.
Um,
can you imagine saying that as American seriously?
You know,
is we're putting up cheesecake factories in the Middle East.
All right.
August 1st,
Belfast UK.
Um,
August 2nd,
I'm in Galway,
Ireland,
uh,
which is way out on the west coast and evidently the closest airport is like a
fucking hour away from it.
So I don't understand what this is.
This is seems like,
should I ruin it?
And it actually fucking Google some pictures of it.
Galway,
Ireland.
Let's see,
we got here.
Okay.
Oh
my God.
Jesus cry.
I know it.
I know.
This is going to be one of these fucking,
uh,
which is a warlock,
one of those fucking movies type cities.
Harry Potter.
Look at this fucking place.
Oh my God.
I'm only spending a day there.
Okay.
Wow.
Look at the fucking castles.
Holy Shit.
Okay.
I'm going to drive in there,
do the show,
and then I got to drive right back so I can make my flight.
What the fuck am I going?
Yeah.
Did I fuck it up?
What am I going next?
All right,
I'll go to a all,
then I fly to a Bristol,
England,
and then Manchester,
England.
The,
a sober,
sophisticated Manchester.
I'm thinking that's going to be a nice mellow crowd
fucking loaded takes.
Um,
that's what I'm anticipating.
A Manchester.
I,
I'm anticipating they're going to be a bunch of fucking lunatic switches.
A which is fine by me.
I um,
I grew up Massachusetts,
you know,
London,
England,
August 5th and August six with the country critics.
Uh,
August 7th,
I'll be in Amsterdam and then August 8th,
I will be in Edinburgh,
uh,
for two shows.
All right.
So we got a late show too.
Okay.
Um,
then I got a couple of days off,
well,
be hanging out with other orange headed conflict myself.
And then August 11th,
um,
in Germany,
Cologne,
Germany,
bodywash,
Germany.
Then August 12th,
I'm in Antwerp,
Belgium.
Oh look at this.
August 27,
I'm in Reno,
Reno,
Nevada,
Nevada.
And at that point we will be only a couple of months away from that fucking
kitchen TV square headed,
fucking safe,
crazy eyes smiling psycho from becoming the next fucking president of the United
States.
Oh,
that's going to be a rough one.
Watching all these ladies saying how fucking,
what an important date is for women.
I guess it will be because a woman to be elected president,
this is just my prediction here.
All right.
But,
uh,
Jesus Christ couldn't,
we have gotten one that didn't have 58 pending fucking felonies.
That's not a red flag to anybody,
you know,
I dunno.
What are you going to do?
Those are our choices.
I don't know why
a fucking maniac who,
uh,
you know,
it doesn't know how to use email properly.
You know,
sending out secrets to a French.
Um,
and that's some fucking guy who's a,
I dunno,
who really should just be a carnival barker.
I feel like Trump should just standing next to some impossible game to when
talking about how it's the greatest game ever.
You know,
who's he hits on underage chicks.
Um,
I don't know.
That's just,
just,
just the opinions of somebody who,
uh,
can't pronounce words while he reads out loud.
What he say,
what he say they cleo.
That's the,
uh,
that's the podcast here for this,
this Thursday afternoon.
MMM.
Could sell.
Oh,
I,
you know what?
Somebody please send me a fucking,
whatever you call a Photoshop picture of fucking Rappaport's face on Danny
Ainge,
his body when he played for the Celtics.
I really want to see that to it.
You can do whatever the fuck you want to do with my head.
You know,
I don't give a fuck.
That's it.
All right.
I got to go hit the elliptical.
So I'm not a fucking fat fuck at the end of this writing season here.
Congratulations to Kevin Durant.
Um,
on your next,
uh,
on your,
on your first championship ring.
You know,
I want to put together a standup tour like that.
You know what I mean?
I want to join like the,
uh,
like if Louis C CK and Dave ship Dave Chappelle would doing like a stand up
tour,
I'd somehow like,
I know know,
I don't know.
I do like their neck standup specials.
I'll splice part of my hour in there.
Get credit.
Uh,
all right,
that's it.
Um,
you guys have a great weekend.
Your conscience
and I'll,
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Enjoy the music and another half hour of Monday morning podcast back from
yesteryear.
Z.
Let's see
is got ma'am
two.
Wait,
Jeez.
Hey,
what's going on?
And uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast that I'm actually doing from my home home
phone rather than my cell phone.
I finally figured out how to call him this,
this,
my space.
A fucking Jesus Christ.
I'm having one of those weeks.
All right.
I just talk.
I just babbled for 12 minutes and decided that I didn't like it and I have to
fucking start all over again.
I don't want to do this.
Do you think I want to do this?
I don't want to fucking do this.
You know,
sometimes in life you got to do what you got.
Yeah.
You'd only you just fucking podcast man.
How long these things take?
Some weeks I get on here,
you know,
I just babbled.
It's just,
it's fucking gold.
Just half hour just running my God damn mouth.
I don't even have to think.
And then there's other times it's,
it's just,
it's like shoveling wet snow.
And you know what,
I'm fucking stick in this one out because I'm not going to start over again.
Eight sometimes.
You know what?
Sometimes you just not that funny.
You fucking,
mine's broken up or whatever.
I don't know.
Let's just get down to goddamn brass tacks here and I'll let you know what I got
going on.
All right.
My name is bill bar.
This is my myspace page.
This is my Monday morning podcast.
I do one of these every God damn week.
Okay.
It's try to give people a nice laugh to start off to fucking weeks and uh,
and we start off in a good mood.
And then I ended up getting frustrated with my own ineptness and then I ended up
just fucking,
I dunno,
ended up snapping and I say fuck a lot.
All right.
And uh,
okay,
let's get on with people asked me questions,
I answer them.
Look at me.
I'm just,
you know,
I'm just blowing through this.
Just blowing through the explanations.
I usually take my time and explain this.
You know what this is like.
You ever like break your arm or something and you go to school.
The next day instance,
the first kid goes,
hey man,
what happened to your arm?
Right?
And you give them every last fucking detail.
Okay?
But then by the time you've told the fucking story,
it said like the 12th person.
By the time the 13th person comes up to you,
you're like,
I fucking fell down.
All right.
What the fuck you think happened?
You know,
that's the mindset I'm in right now as I do this podcast.
After just blow in 12 minutes of arise and call him on my home phone.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Let's get down with this shit here.
Let's get,
get on with it.
I put up a new video because I am desperately trying to get myself to become
part of the new millennium.
It's right underneath the podcast.
If you look there,
you'll see a very blurry,
very blurry me and a Winnipeg jets shirt,
by the way,
cause I'm old school,
old school hooky.
Um,
let's meet at the punchline in Atlanta and before you watch the video,
I just want to give you a little backstory.
What happened.
Uh,
I was actually,
it was Thursday night and a couple of weeks ago and it's one of my favorite
clubs now.
It's just having one of these awesome sets where I was,
uh,
I was really open and free and everything was just flowing as opposed to this
podcast,
which feels very arduous,
very work like that.
I used that word correctly.
Want to fuck is quest love wearing those fucking lime green pants?
I just realized that,
um,
anyways,
I was having one of these,
um,
one of these just,
you know,
really open just great sets and I was about 12 minutes in and everybody was
laughing.
Everybody's having a good time.
I was having a good time,
but for some reason there was this lady in the crowd and it wasn't enough that
she felt my jokes were funny.
She was somehow agreeing with the things that I was saying on stage.
So rather than laughing at the end of every joke,
you know,
when the punchline came out,
instead of laughing,
she would just yell out Sankyo after every joke,
you know,
the rest of the crowd was booby laughing and then I would just hear this woman's
voiceover,
everybody thank Yo.
So this video picks up about 12 minutes into my set.
She's already,
I'll tag yo like fucking 12 times.
And I feel it annoying.
That is with me saying that to you.
Just imagine being on stage,
trying to keep the crowd,
trying to keep the fucking plates spinning and somebody keeps yelling that shit
out.
So she yells it out for I guess basically the sixth time.
And that's when I finally snapped.
I snapped in a good way.
I was proud of myself where I didn't shop her head off and be overly mean.
It's kind of mean,
but it was definitely funny.
And,
um,
I just want to let you guys know I'm,
I'm going to start taping all my sets because,
uh,
you know,
I riff a lot and I end up,
missing a lot of good lines that I could keep in my act and also random shit
happens and I'm going to start posting some of the random shit that,
that,
uh,
happens up here.
Um,
unless people really start to enjoy these.
And then they come out to my shows and then they deliberately tried to yell out
something,
which is always the risk of it.
But basically I like doing this kind of thing because I want to give you guys
some new,
some new laughs without having to burn any material.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
I'm not Trent Reznor here.
I can't just give away my new hour for free,
you know,
like he can,
I'm jealous and musicians,
right?
They can just fucking put the goddamn music out for free now.
And then everybody comes to their shows and when they know all the words,
they get to sing along.
So it's different than he can go,
you know,
we're going to break it down in Detroit,
can break it down here.
Right.
And then he'd been in,
he slows the fucking song down and then everybody go,
whatever.
It brings the music level down and everybody thinks along,
you can't do that with jokes.
Maybe if I started singing my jokes and then I'll do that.
I'll come with a fucking Ukulele on stage,
you know,
if I could fucking sing.
That's why guitar x blow up,
man telling you fucking telling you.
I heard about some kid in Massachusetts.
He's the kid.
Uh,
he's been putting funny songs up on Youtube for the last year and he just sold
out the comedy connection.
It's like 17 fucking years old,
you know,
long.
It took me to sell out to common connection,
15 fucking years telling jokes.
You know why?
Because I don't sing.
I would just sing my God damn jokes.
What's the deal with labs?
Everybody,
if I would just do that,
I would just do that.
I don't know you,
I dunno what would happen.
You know,
something you always want to think,
you know.
I just did that.
Then I'd be here.
You'd ever think of all the failed guitar acts?
You know the ones that you guys don't see?
You just see the successful ones.
You know the ones with their half hour specials,
the ones selling out theaters.
All right.
You don't see the ones that opened for me when I go to Portland,
Oregon,
or at least when I did back in the day,
way back in the day,
10 years ago,
he's played a club called Harvey's.
Oh,
I remember.
It was,
the walls were green and the guy used to,
he used to give the whole show away,
which basically he would have telemarketers call people up and just be like,
Hey,
guess what?
You've won tickets to what you want for free tickets to a comedy show.
And the people would be like,
Holy Shit,
how the fuck did I win?
Knows I didn't even enter the contest,
you know?
Well,
you won them because a comedy was not selling well 10 years ago.
So these,
to give them,
basically they've given away the show.
He'd walk into this fucking place.
It'd be a Tuesday,
you know,
I'd come Mosey and,
and I'm thinking,
I'll write the Tuesday.
It'll be half full.
Knows who the fuck I am.
I lean on the mic stand,
I'll riff.
I'll gets the new jokes.
And you would walk in there and you would think that Springsteen was going to
come on.
It was jam packed 400 fucking drunk ass people who didn't know me and did not
give a shit whether the show was good or not really,
because they already felt like they had,
they had already want,
they got free tickets.
So you would go up there and it would just be,
it'd be a fucking zoo who would be an absolute zoo and a,
a lot of lumberjack that,
that was the vibe I got.
You know,
Oregon has a lot of trees and he'd be down there in Portland and you'd be
thinking,
all right,
it's very crunchy,
very sort of progressive.
But,
uh,
you know,
those cops don't come out to shows.
The lumberjacks would come out and they'd be screaming and yelling and eaten
burgers that would have fried eggs on the top of them.
And,
uh,
and it sucked.
And I don't even know why I'm talking about that.
I already forgot I spaced halfway through that fucking story because,
um,
cause that's the mindset I'm in this week.
I,
you know what it is,
I got a zillion fucking things I got to take care of because I'm on my way to
Pittsburgh this week and I'm flying in a day early,
uh,
to do,
um,
I'm doing a lot of radio this week cause I'm going to try to sell that fucking
place out.
I want to be on our wd VIII with Randy Bowman this week.
Um,
and if I had any fucking brains,
I would have looked that up and giving you the,
I don't know,
it's 100 points something.
I think if you live in Pittsburgh,
you can listen to me and I'll be honest.
Say you listened to me in the morning,
Wednesday morning,
Thursday morning and Friday morning,
and then he'd come out on the weekend,
he check out my show just for the love of God.
Just come up to my goddamn shit.
Okay.
I don't know.
Fucking,
I don't want to tell you.
Um,
please,
I don't want to stand there alone.
I can't,
that that mall is the most depressing fucking mall in America for those of you
who've never been to it,
that Pittsburgh Improv is an a mall called the stack.
Um,
why do they call it the stacks?
Basically?
Because I guess the mall used to be a steel mill.
Okay.
When we used to have industry and this country before they started telling us
that everything was too expensive to make in this country.
So they had the,
you know,
ship it to a third world country and have some eight year old kid,
kid make fucking spittoons or whatever the fuck it is.
You make a goddamn steel steel mill,
right.
Rather than being like,
now all Americans are involved with unions and they want health insurance and
they want to get paid for their work.
They,
they,
they just,
they just fucking picked up and left.
But this is what they did.
They knocked down the factory,
but they,
uh,
they kept the stacks.
Just to remind you that,
that people,
uh,
you know,
there's this reminded me,
might even be a poltergeist.
You know,
you move the headstones,
but she's had moved the bodies.
That's what they did at that mall.
They moved the factory,
but they left the smokestacks.
That's what they did to remind you that hardworking Americans used to have jobs
there and they could support their families and they made shit out of steel that
other Americans would then buy.
Okay?
And the dollar was worth something,
but they got rid of all that.
They shipped it somewhere else.
And in it's wake,
they left fucking cheesecake factory's lucky jeans and the fucking cold stone
creamery.
But in tribute to all those people that they fucked over,
they left the chimneys.
Isn't that nice?
A little nod to the past and now they're fucking kids.
What are they doing?
What are they,
where do they work
given notice that when you meet people and they come up to you,
you ask him what the fuck they do.
You don't even get to kitty.
You don't even know what it is.
What do you do?
I worked in a steel mill.
Okay.
You work in a mill,
the steel there,
and you work there.
So you work with steel in a mill.
I get that.
I understand what that job is.
What do you do?
I'm the Milkman.
Okay.
You're a man.
There's milk and you fucking deliver it,
man.
You're the Milkman.
I get it.
I fucking get it.
You realize how many jobs there are that people actually understand what the
fuck it is you do now.
There's very few left.
I'm a mail man.
I'm a man.
I delivered mail.
I'm the fucking mailman back then.
They was simple,
simple fucking names.
All right.
I'm a silver Smith.
All right?
Smith meaning,
uh,
like to,
to hit with a hammer,
like smile and I'll do it with silver.
A fucking silver Smith.
All right.
There wasn't any,
the A,
I'm the regional director of the fucking,
you know,
so I can't even,
I can't even give you an example of somebody's job.
I'm trying to think of the,
all these computer.
I sit in a cubicle and make somebody else's dream happen.
I'm telling you right now,
man,
it's just sitting in a fucking cubicle.
Just do something rebellious today.
Just take one of the screws out of your fake.
I don't really have an office wall that they put in front of you to make you
feel like you have half an office.
But the reality is they don't want you looking at other people.
You know,
I think I've talked about this before.
You guys ever see that movie,
the apartment starring a Jack Lemmon.
If you see the beginning of that movie,
that's what the cubicle area used to look like.
You still had a sea of people,
you know,
slugging away looking like a bunch of goddamn salmon swimming upstream with
fucking typewriters in front of them.
But they didn't have walls around them like they were on punishment.
You know,
you could look at the person next to you shoot the shit,
but then somewhere along the line they let us know that they're fucking talking.
We can't have them looking at themselves.
They're literally treating you like children
and said,
I don't know.
It's just fucking,
it just blows my mind.
You know what I mean?
I,
I'd rather sell drugs.
All right.
Um,
so anyways,
this is the,
yeah,
this is the Monday morning podcast and a,
if people send me questions,
if you knew to my page,
if you haven't defected to fucking Facebook,
like the fact that you are,
you know what I mean?
I love all these people go on to Facebook now.
Like,
like the same herd of assholes that went from Friendster to my space.
Isn't,
isn't gonna,
you know,
they're not going to eventually end up over there.
Like there's not going to be a bunch of spam about ringtones and a bunch of
whores with the butt cracks and that titties hanging out,
you know,
sending you generic emails trying to make it seem like they didn't send it to
everybody else,
but you realize that they did because rather than calling you by your name,
it just says,
Hey,
you love your page
by the way,
I'm the fucking Nokia phone whore or the month or whatever the hell they,
you know,
all the stupid beauty contest things that they go to when,
um,
I'm sticking it out here,
man.
All right.
And all you guys who all going over to Facebook,
you know,
what you liked,
you liked that.
You ever see that movie the titanic,
when as those guys,
you know who fucking jumped in into the RAF's all by themselves,
they'll Celsus sons of bitches who were actually smart,
who listened to that voice that says,
I need to fucking survive.
Well,
maybe they are smart.
Then maybe they realize that my space,
maybe my space is a sinking ship.
You know?
I don't know.
That'd be actually kind of funny now because they've already made their money
off it.
Rupert Murdoch already brought about this thing.
You mean $1 billion?
Every fucking content.
Um,
alright,
I answer questions here.
I'm really just babbling here.
Um,
I answered questions here every week.
People send me questions.
Um,
I try to answer them to the best of my ability.
And uh,
here we go here,
there the podcast.
So the week,
um,
oh,
and by the way,
when you watch my video,
could you please send me a comment if you like it or whatever.
Cause that's like a new thing that I really want to start doing.
Just putting some random moments up there like that.
Um,
so,
so let me,
let me know.
Let me know what you think.
Okay.
Question number one.
Hey Bill,
which one was better?
Mike Richters insane.
Safe Against Pawel Bureau.
That's how you saying Pablo Obra never know what to say.
These Russian guys names.
It's insane.
Save against his penalty shot or Patrick wa Mike Vernon going at its center
rice.
I'm definitely gonna say Mike Richter,
just because,
uh,
that was,
that was one of the best years ever in hockey.
That was like 2004 when the red sox finally wanted to watch the rangers finally
when the cup and everybody go crazy.
That was just an amazing moment.
And,
uh,
the Patrick,
while Mike Berning thin,
you know,
I don't know,
was it,
you know,
it was a great fight.
It's great to see Patrick while loose,
but you know,
that owns for the Stanley Cup.
And I remember watching that 1994 and watching the rangers went in.
I remember thinking clearly that's what it's going to be like when the red sox,
if they ever get their heads out of their asses and they finally fucking win
one,
that that's going to be what it's like.
So,
uh,
I was living vicariously and for some reason I didn't hate the Rangers for the
simple fact that I was not old enough when the rangers last time,
the Rangers Bruins rivalry was great,
which was back in the 70s.
I was still just a,
just a little lad with a big Motha fucking red hair looking like that dude Jody
on a family affair.
All right.
And that's why I became a comedian because that's who the fuck I look like.
And I got the shit kicked out of me.
Um,
all right,
question number two,
Bill.
How the hell does Paris Hilton keep getting movie roles?
Well,
I actually thought about this one and I think the reason that she keeps getting
movie roles is because,
uh,
not to be crude,
but,
uh,
she's not afraid to show the clamp,
you know?
And uh,
I think,
uh,
you know,
I think that's how,
that's how you got to do it sometimes as a woman,
you gotta you gotta just every once in a while you just got to take your pussy
up,
you know,
and,
uh,
I don't think there's anything wrong with it.
Sharon Stone did it.
Sharon Stone was,
you know,
meandering around all these fucking B movies.
She,
you know,
she had it halfway decent role in some sort of Schwartz and angle movie,
but it wasn't until she showed the clam that people's,
you know,
sat up and took notice.
Next thing you know,
she's in that movie casino and delivered one of the best performances.
I thought she,
she,
she was,
she nominated for an Oscar.
She should've won,
won that year.
But that's when showing the clam kind of harder because all the other women
resented her.
You know what I mean?
They thought that she was a whore rather than she did what she had to do.
And I don't understand what women get upset
when they're like,
you know,
you're treating me like a a,
like a sexual object and it's like you are a sexual object.
You know what I mean?
That's like you.
I'm like,
oh you're just fucking using me because I can pick up heavy shit.
I can't pick up.
I mean,
not extra heavy shit but heavier shit.
Cause I'm a guy,
you know,
that's where Hillary Clinton fucked up her campaign.
When she fucking put on the pants suit,
you know,
she should have sex that up a little vamped it up.
God gave you Teddy's use them show low cleavage.
You know what I mean?
That's what she should've done.
And people,
you know,
if you think that's still on,
it's stupid.
You know,
guys don't get elected because of their brains.
Bill Clinton got elected because he played the saxophone on fucking Arsenio
Hall.
And when our CTO came in to do the black handshake,
somehow Bill Clinton was able to do it without fucking breaking his wrist.
And I think that right there was,
when was,
when was the turning of it?
What else did he do?
He just sat there smiling with his mouth open,
going change America wants change.
He didn't say anything.
He played the fucking saxophone.
So if you're a woman,
you know,
show little titty share a little tinny,
that's all.
That's all I can tell you.
Oh God,
I'm so ignorant.
All right.
Uh,
question number three.
Bill.
Uh,
but,
but I put down what the fuck is this one?
Um,
all right,
thanks for answering my questions or this is an up and coming comedian and I
competed in a funniest person contest in a city that I will not,
I'm not going to name cause I don't get this person in trouble just in case one
of my 14 listeners is the club owner of that.
Anyways,
the owner said that he would not hire any of the comedians to work for any of
the clubs because we were too vulgar.
The crazy thing is I noticed that it was an older crowd,
but I was being stubborn and decided to do my normal routine,
which is some dirty jokes.
And your opinion,
do you think you're selling out if you adjust your comedic style to get into the
big corporate clubs?
Um,
okay.
all right.
I know what you're saying here.
I've done the same thing.
Um,
I've looked out in the crowd going,
okay,
this is what I want to talk about.
You look at them,
you judge them and you go,
well,
I'm going to be eating my balls,
at least 40% of my set if I stick with what I want to do.
And um,
yeah,
when you want 100% adjust your act,
you yeah.
You definitely,
yeah.
You feel dirty,
you know,
not,
not them,
not to use a pun there,
but yeah.
You don't feel good.
But,
uh,
it isn't 100% selling out if,
you know,
I don't know.
It's one of those weird things where it's your own judgment call.
You know what I mean?
Because I used to do those Naca things for the,
for those of you who aren't comedians here,
they have these things every year.
Um,
these,
these national showcases for college gigs.
And when I used to showcase for them,
I would go up and I would just do my act,
you know?
And I remember one year,
something that was going on in my act was the first time I got,
you know,
an HIV test.
And I was talking about the fear of it,
which is,
and it's really not a joke that you want to do when a college showcase.
He just want to do you're happy shit.
And I did.
And I was like,
fuck dead man,
I'm fucking selling out.
So I went up there and I did my shit.
And you know what?
I got zero schools and I just got people,
they kept coming up to me going,
we think you're hilarious.
You know,
they kept getting the whole world,
who was up to me,
I book you,
but I can't because of blah,
blah,
blah.
And what I learned was sometimes you gotta play the game a little bit.
So what I would then do was I would go up,
after that,
I would go up and do a squeaky clean set.
Then I would book the colleges.
And then when I went to the colleges,
I would actually then do my act and then do the shit that I wanted to talk
about.
So in a weird way,
I actually want,
cause I got the money and I still got to do what I wanted to do.
And I got people to hear the material,
more people to hear the material that I wanted them to hear.
I just had to be a,
I had wore myself out,
you know,
I had to put on a Tuxedo for like fucking five,
six minutes cheesy.
You just brought up a really bad fucking memory.
Um,
no,
but dude,
I would say,
you know,
on your way up.
Yeah.
Nobody wants,
you know,
a lot of headliners don't want to go on in front of a guy who kills.
And they also don't want to go on in front of a guy who's,
you know,
if you,
if you're being a little dirty,
that gives them an excuse to kind of be like,
not just say that I can't follow this guy.
There'll be like,
oh,
he's just being dirty.
So,
uh,
yeah,
play the game a little bit.
You know,
you play the game a little bit and then it is people get to know who you are.
You get way more leeway and uh,
eventually,
uh,
you get to,
do you think,
you know what I mean?
It's one of those things you gotta be like a tree,
you know,
bend but don't break.
You know,
I dunno,
do whatever the fuck you want to do,
but you know,
uh,
I don't know.
That's my 2 cents.
I don't fucking know.
I have no confidence in my God damn opinion,
so I don't even know why you people ask me questions.
All right.
Question number four.
Ah,
Bill,
have you been approached about doing any shows since your skits on Chappelle?
Um,
yeah,
catch one every year and I try to get them on TV.
But um,
for those of you who always asked me,
how come you don't have your own TV show?
Um,
because it's really hard.
It's all I can tell you.
Okay.
It's very hard to get a show on TV because believe it or not,
a lot of people want to get a show on television because you can make a lot of
money.
So A,
I keep getting closer.
Keep getting closer.
I'm a bell.
What do you think about Shaq's rap about Colby?
Who was the d bag and this never ending saga?
I think Shaq was just fucking around.
I thought he was joking,
but he wasn't joking,
but he was joking.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
if somebody gets arrested for a potential rape and they bring my name up during
it,
you know,
um,
I think I have the license to give him shit for a while.
And if I'm in a club and I want to fucking make fun of them a little bit.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I just looked at Chuck's face.
I thought he was clearly joking around and it was so over the top.
Colby,
how,
how's my ass taste?
I mean,
I don't know.
How does it take check?
Like you've been running full court for the last 15 years where the disgusting
question.
All right.
Uh,
number five.
We got a lot of questions this week and we try to blow through them.
Um,
well went to the Tempe Improv,
saw this comic.
He was good,
but the opening act was killing it.
He was so funny.
Do you ever get worried or stressed that your openers going to be more funny
than you?
Um,
is there any sort of process you go through picking your opener?
Am I worried about them being more funny?
Uh,
well,
no,
I'm not.
They're fucking middle acts for a reason.
All right.
If you can't follow a Middle Act,
then you're,
you're not a headliner.
I've definitely had some funny guys on in front of me.
Um,
but I think that's a good thing.
You know what I mean?
You don't want to be sparring with somebody who sucks because then you're going
to end up sucking.
So I believe in going out with a hit man,
you know,
bringing in a middle act that's,
funny and an original.
And that's my process to picking an opener.
I use Joe to Rosa,
Kevin Shay.
I'm going to be using this guy,
Todd wrecks up in San Francisco.
These guys,
Todd wrecks,
you know in particular,
no disrespect to those other two cops,
but he really fucking kills.
So I'll have my work cut out for me that week.
But uh,
yeah,
I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to have some guy who just goes up there with like a lampshade on
his head and stinks.
While these are a lot of questions here is,
is podcasts getting too long?
All right.
Uh,
it'd be like,
got a question for you podcasts.
Do you ever get a chance to meet George Carlin?
Um,
unfortunately,
no,
I didn't.
I was supposed to meet him.
Um,
when was it?
February or March,
right before he did his specialty.
He's supposed to be doing the comedy and Magic Club down on her most of the
beach.
And I had just done a spot down there and they said,
hey,
he's coming in you whatever.
On a Wednesday or a Tuesday if you can come down and watch the show and you can
meet him afterwards and it was going to be a dream come true.
But,
um,
he ended up getting sick.
Obviously his health was failing and uh,
he ended up canceling,
so I never got a chance to meet him.
But I did get a chance to see him and
he absolutely blew me away.
And it was actually with a long time.
I was like 20 years ago before I was even doing comedy and a,
I did at least get the same cause I never got to see prior.
So at least I can say that I saw him and I'm with him.
Passing is really making me want to go see Don Rickles because,
uh,
you know,
that guy's in his eighties and he's still fucking hilarious and a,
I don't know.
He should,
you know,
the comedian,
I think anybody likes comedy,
he should see those guys.
So,
no,
I did not get a chance to meet him,
but I did get to see him in person and obviously he's,
you can see on my page.
He was a huge influence on me,
obviously.
Um,
all right.
All right.
What are we doing here?
Two more questions and then I'm gonna wrap this fucking thing up.
Number seven,
Bill.
Um,
do you,
okay,
I got,
she got a fucking asked advice here on dating.
Do you know I'm fucking not married at 40 and somebody is asking me advice on
relationships.
Okay,
you really need to consider your sources here.
Um,
all right.
That's like,
why don't you go ask somebody on heroin?
Do you think math is bad?
You know,
pain.
And if you like doing it,
you should fucking do it.
All right,
here we go.
Well,
do you think a person deserves more than one date to determine if there was
chemistry?
I recently went out on a date with a guy.
Turns out he wasn't my type.
Well,
there's your answer right there.
But he had a nice personality,
but I feel you should know you should feel something immediately.
You're answering your questions.
Uh,
it's not like he was my friend to begin with or will be my friend
that'll have time to grow on me.
I feel very mean and superficial.
Oh,
whoa.
Okay.
There you go.
Right there.
There's your first mistake with dating.
When you date,
you have to be unbelievably selfish,
unbelievably selfish,
or you're not going to get what you want.
And it's not even being selfish because if you settle for something that you
don't want,
you're not going to be happy.
Okay?
And then you're going to make the other person miserable.
And that's not fair to the other person.
So fuck that guy.
All right.
Fuck him in his nice personality.
Hook them up with another one of your friends.
Say,
Hey,
I met a guy that I'm not into,
but he has a nice personality.
You know what I mean?
That's like a,
that's like watching a TV show that you don't enjoy,
but you really liked the look of it.
The end of it.
You don't like the fucking show.
So how long are you going to be interested?
You know?
You know,
I don't know.
It's like friends.
I used to watch friends when I lived in New York City.
I was like,
God,
look at that apartment,
which had a fucking huge apartment like that,
but I hated the fucking show.
So at the end of the day,
I didn't watch the show.
How long can you look at the couch?
All right,
question number.
Hey,
this is the final question now bill,
why a while?
This is a cheesy question.
I'm a chef,
so I always ask,
um,
and I,
so I always ask and I think the answer says a lot.
What is your favorite food?
Slash?
Restaurant?
Ah,
what does my favorite food?
I like steak.
Um,
and I really liked that steak and shake,
you know,
uh,
it's got two things.
I really enjoy.
Red Meat and a shakes.
No.
Um,
I'm really,
I don't know.
I liked everything.
I would say Italian.
I think Italians make the best food hands down and uh,
it's absolutely delish and um,
you know,
the olive oil and just,
you know what I love about Italians who really know how to cook.
They know how to add stuff.
Like they don't like,
I like explain it like whatever they add enhances the dish.
It doesn't overpower it.
You know what I mean?
Like take like the art of making pizza somewhere along the line.
The cheese on the pizza rather than enhancing the taste of the sauce.
The cheese became the focal point.
Okay.
I can't explain it.
Like it became the lead in the movie when it was actually,
you know the,
the the guy who had two lines in the movie,
it's like,
Oh look,
pizza hut.
They got it all over.
They got it in the cross.
They got it everywhere.
You're just seen a big brick of cheese and it tastes like fucking shit and you
can't move your bowels afterwards.
That I like Italian food.
I like the olive oil that they cook with.
I just,
you know,
it's very clean.
You know,
you drink that,
you know,
it's sip a wine.
As long as you don't eat like,
like you're going to the fucking all of garden.
You just feel great.
You take your time.
It's a whole thing.
That's what I like about Italian food and restaurants,
like the whole thing,
the lighting,
the ambiance,
everything.
Um,
so anyways,
with that,
my uh,
my favorite restaurant when I was in New York was a,
I used to really,
I liked the lupa.
That was my favorite one,
the Mario Batali one and out here in la,
one of the best ones I went to,
I haven't been to a lot out here.
I went to a Mozart,
which is a,
another Mario Batali one,
but I'm,
I'm sort of like a hacky restaurant guy worth,
they have a show on the food network.
I ended up going to it like,
you know that you don't have blonde guy who wears the sunglasses backwards on
his head.
He's actually a favorite chef of Joe to Rosa's,
I forget his fucking name,
but he just goes around the diners and that type of shit.
And I hated his restaurant in Sacramento and it was one of the worst fucking
things I ever went to.
He actually had,
I think I talked about it,
he had,
he had the Sushi roll that had pork and French fries in it with some sort of
barbecue sauce and it wasn't rice.
I don't know what it was.
It was some sort of pasty thing.
It was absolutely fucking disgusting and it's in Sacramento,
don't go to it.
And uh,
they go,
that's the end of the fucking podcast questions.
Um,
um,
I think that's it.
I think that's it for the week.
Also,
I trashed best buy last week said I wasn't going to go there anymore because
they had that 15% restocking fee.
Somebody sent me an email about that,
that if you buy something there and you don't like it and you bring it back,
they still charge you 15% of it to just stick it back on the shelf.
So some best buy person wrote,
why work at best buy and trust me,
it's necessary.
They do it mainly on computers because when we sell one,
we only make about 20 bucks in profit.
Really?
Is that how you keep that big store open?
You make $20 on each laptop?
I don't buy that and when someone decides to return it,
if we have to sell it for below cost,
no you don't.
I've never gone into best buy and seen a TV or anything that says uh,
everything there is full price.
What are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm going to give you the better for the dental.
I'm not going to give you the benefit of the doubt because best buy my Sanshou
Sir who wrote this fucking thing,
but you worked for an evil fucking place that put mom and pop fucking places out
of business.
Okay.
Back in the day when you return something,
they just returned it.
They put it back in the fucking box and they stuck it on the shelf.
They didn't charge a 15% okay.
That's one of those exploiting new revenue streams,
new way to come up with extra money to fuck the customer.
I firmly believe that.
I've been in best buy,
I've shopped in best buy,
I've never seen any use cds and he used computers.
Everything is brand new.
Okay,
so maybe you got to clarify that.
Is there some sort of off the rack best buy thing down the street?
Uh,
best buy part too.
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
I'm still saying fuck best buy.
So why don't you write me a followup?
Okay.
I know it was a bit of a cunt there,
so explain it further because I don't get it.
So anyways,
that's the podcast for the week.
Thanks to everybody who sent me in all the God damn questions.
And
what am I going to say here?
Uh,
yeah,
I'm going to be at the,
uh,
the Improv in Pittsburgh this week for the love of God.
Please come out.
I got a brand new hour that I'm really proud of and uh,
it's really depressing to be at that God damn mall with the stacks.
You know,
the poltergeist stacks,
this fucking chimneys there.
Okay.
I'm going to the pirates game Wednesday night.
All right.
It'll be me and 30 other fucking people there.
So you'll be able to see me come up to come up to me and say,
what's up a Wednesday night against the Astros.
Um,
further news.
I'll be in the,
uh,
comedy works in Denver in First Week of August.
Um,
and what else?
I got the Improv in Miami.
I've got a bunch of gigs coming up.
I have an upcoming tour and upcoming,
our special coming out August 23rd on comedy central.
If I had half a brain and would have said that at the beginning of this podcast.
Um,
am I new CD is coming out August 3rd,
and I think that's it.
Please keep the questions coming and,
uh,
and that is it.
Thanks for listening to the podcast.
You guys have yourself a great week.
All right.
Take it easy.
[inaudible] no
days.
Yeah,
no
loud
[inaudible]
Oh,
big
three
intake.
Go Away.
Show it's been a baby.
And as Batman sweet,
shallow allowed to come on back.
Come on back.
Come on number
two.